[THEME MUSIC]
TOM GALIZIA: Thank
you for coming.
How was the morning session?
OK, fantastic.
It really is great to
sort of see you all here.
It's bright up here.
But this is exactly
the right time for us
to connect and collaborate
here at Google Next
to really understand and shape
our futures in real time.
I'd say in the 25 years
that I've been at Deloitte,
I've gotten to do many,
many exciting things
in many exciting places
with great clients.
But the last 19 months
working with Alphabet Google
and the Google
Cloud team has been
one of the most intellectually
enriching times of my career.
But also I found myself
targeting market impact
at a scale that, you know,
added a comma, honestly.
It's a watermark high for me.
It's been a great and successful
partnership with Google
over the last 19 months.
And we are very happy that we
received Google Cloud's Global
Services Partner of the Year.
This award is really a
recognition of real laser
focus, as many of you know, a
great team, a ton of hard work,
and really unwavering commitment
to collaborating and leveraging
our collective strengths
of both Google Cloud
and what Deloitte can
bring to our clients
to really re-imagine, many of
you re-imagine your businesses,
and execute with
technology-enabled innovations.
We have multiple
client-centric solutions.
The press has hit it recently,
"CRN" news last week.
We issued a press
release, as well.
These are important because it
talks to the kinds of impacts
and value we can bring
to your clients, to you
as clients, every day.
Google Cloud, SAP, and
Deloitte have rich histories
with one another.
And we've come
together and really are
committed to working with you to
take advantage of the business
opportunities that
you see, that we see,
and take advantage and overcome
the challenges that many
of our business leaders face.
To get us in sort
of the right mindset
for the panel and
the discussion,
I wanted to share
a powerful message
on how fast the
world is changing.
We've seen this
many, many times.
But it's really impacting
virtually every aspect
of our lives.
And with two amazing young
children, nine and 11,
at home--
and for those of you who
are parents in the audience,
I'm guarantee this video will
make you pause for a minute
and think about the world we are
creating for them to thrive in.
So without further ado,
let's go to the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is Alex.
She's five years old.
And she was born
into a digital world
at the edge of a
technological singularity
where she could live
to be 150 years old.
Imagine all the advances
of the last 150 years,
each discovery
building on the last
to alter the way we live,
relate, consume, and perceive.
For Alex, that same amount of
industrial and societal change
will happen in her next 15.
She'll purchase digital
rights from brands
to create her own clothing,
furniture, and decor
with digital fabrics.
She'll eat
organically-balanced food
that was grown using nanotech.
She'll know someone
whose life was
saved by a 3D-printed organ
implanted by a doctor operating
remotely.
She'll carry safer,
digitally-integrated ID
and forms of payment, driven by
the blockchain of everything.
And that's just until she's 20.
She still has 130 years to go.
As she enters the
workforce, she'll
take advantage of
autonomous vehicles
and ride share
programs which will
alter our entire
transportation infrastructure.
She'll have robotic
and AI-driven support
tools, and even colleagues.
The very notion of an
employee will change.
All these advancements
will open us up
to a new world of
imagined possibilities.
What role will your
enterprise play
in creating this
world, her world?
You'll need to embrace it
as a freely-moving digital
enterprise, shedding
your technical debt.
If your company is
designed for this decade,
it won't outlast it.
The pace of change will
continue to accelerate.
Enterprises will
have to adapt faster,
all to serve the wants and
needs of a five-year-old.
Her future and your
future are linked.
And leading that future will
be your digital enterprise.
It's time to re-imagine
your business model,
your organization, your world.
It's time to
re-imagine everything.
[END PLAYBACK]
TOM GALIZIA: I'd like to now
invite on stage three business
leaders, change agents, and
real, true collaborators
and personal friends of mine.
Kevin Ichhpurani, Jan
Waals, and Pavan Srivastava.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So thank you guys
for joining us today.
Can you please maybe start
with just a little bit
of background,
your current role?
And I know all of you are
very deep and steeped in SAP,
so share a little bit
about that with us.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: All
right, Pavan Srivastava.
I'm part of our
technology practice.
And I've been doing work around
SAP for the last 20 years,
definitely focused
more around using
the innovative technologies
around SAP and Cloud and SAP
HANA to transform the business.
And definitely, we're going
through an exciting time
right now.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
JAN WAALS: Jan
Waals for Deloitte.
I lead our Global SAP Practice.
Been working on SAP programs
since I was 15, I think.
So long, long time.
For the firm, I also
led our US practice
during the days of an
up and coming S/4HANA.
Had to transform our
own practice, frankly,
to be able to better serve
our customers, as well.
I'm excited to be here.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: Perfect.
And I'm Kevin Ichhpurani.
I manage global alliances
for Google Cloud,
and also have a long
history of working
with SAP and SAP customers
for the last 15-plus years.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
So maybe we'll start
with you, Kevin.
Very keen to hear about
what you're seeing,
relevant trends, and
sort of the latest
headlines between SAP and
Google and your relationship.
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: So we've
made tremendous progress
over the last year since this
partnership was announced.
In fact, many of you have
seen the video yesterday
in Diane Greene's keynote
from Bernd Leukert,
the head of engineering at SAP,
in which he really underscores
that the relationship is,
the core foundation is
a deep relationship between
the engineering teams
that are sitting side by
side helping to co-innovate
and optimize our solutions to
better support SAP products.
And so I'll give
you some examples.
Over the course
of the last year,
our customers were asking
for all of the SAP solutions
to be certified
for Google Cloud.
And we've done virtually
all of the SAP solutions
are certified now.
In fact, many of
them were asking
for very large landscapes
for the large HANA instances.
And we announced at SAP
Sapphire in June 4 terabyte
availability.
We now announced at Google
Nexus week availability
of 7 terabytes, and
natively, up to 18 terabytes
by the end of next year.
So we can handle the largest
customers in the world.
We are also for customers that
need something very short term,
have a bare metal option
up to 20 terabytes.
So a very significant
improvement on the instance
sizes, in terms of availability.
But we're also
co-innovating with SAP.
We've done things like
integrated BigQuery,
Google BigQuery
with SAP HANA so we
can enable petabyte
scale for SAP HANA
and enable use cases where
large retailers are looking
a tremendous amount of data and
want to do dynamic upselling,
and cross selling,
or genomic profiling.
We're working with SAP
in areas around Android.
So within the core SAP platform,
the SAP Cloud platform,
you can develop native
experiences in Android.
And we're working in areas
around areas like machine
learning, embedding that
into the core business
process of SAP applications.
TOM GALIZIA: And
Kevin, just watching
the speed at which Google
has moved into the SAP space,
it's been nothing
short of impressive
because if you go
24 months ago, all
that you describe that's
happened in that time horizon.
And it's pretty amazing just
to see the engineering talent.
You know, Pavan, I know
you've been working closely
with Google for quite a while
at this point, too, right?
Close to two years.
Let me ask you, what does
it mean for Deloitte,
in your mind, to be not
only a premier partner,
but also to have
been acknowledged
by Kevin and the team
around the Global Services
Partner of the Year?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Yeah,
and I think, first of all,
it's a great honor to
be the Premier Partner.
And also excited to
get the news around us
being the Global Partner of
the Year, which is amazing.
And I think it has
come at the right time.
What that really
means to us is we
are committed to do a lot
more investment into this area
and build our capabilities
around Google Cloud Platform.
And the reality
is, our clients are
going through this digital
transformation with SAP's
new product line, S/4HANA.
And over the next seven years,
we would see a lot of momentum
in the market around
that area, which
means they are expecting
us to help them adapt
to these technologies
and the Cloud platform
together, obviously
understanding the business
benefit of how they can
leverage Cloud Platform
capabilities for business,
how to transform, adapt it,
which also means we are
heavily investing in this area.
And Google Cloud Platform is
one of the important aspect
of our go to market strategy.
So this partnership really means
that we have the highest level
of access within Google,
about the tools, technologies,
innovation, support, and
leadership commitment
to go into the market.
And that is what we are
going to bring to our clients
to transform their business.
Not only that,
with that backdrop
we have also announced our
collaboration and alliance
with Google to
bring our industry
expertise, our vast experience
around SAP implementation,
our talent pool,
as well as Google
Cloud innovative technology,
to help client extend
the digital code platform
capability by leveraging Google
Machine Learning and
Analytics capabilities.
So we're really excited
about this partnership.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
And I know Jan, you sort
of predicted this tsunami
that we're seeing.
I was sort of in the room.
I know Kevin was
at SAP at the time.
This was quite a while ago.
I might ask you for
stock picks later.
But really, what does SAP's
partnership and market
relationship with
Google, what does
that mean to our
collective SAP clients
and to some of the prospective
clients out in the audience?
JAN WAALS: Yeah, so SAP, of
course, has a lot of tools
and accelerators available that
we utilize, as well, to better
serve our customers and
to build, basically,
on top of that.
Now you add Google to
the mix and frankly,
that's going to add a
lot of power, as well,
and additional tools
and accelerators
that will become available
over the next months and years,
basically.
Some of that is
still taking shape.
And frankly, it enables us to
do things for our customers
that simply weren't
possible before.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
And I think, Kevin, fair to ask
you a similar line of thinking.
You know, what does
the Deloitte market
relationship with
Google, what does that
mean for our collective SAP
clients, from your perspective?
KEVIN ICHHPURANI:
I think there's
tremendous value for
clients in that Deloitte
has a long history of
working with SAP clients
and understanding how to
manage the landscapes.
In fact, Deloitte's one
of the largest systems
integrators around
SAP in the world.
And that's what we
particularly found attractive.
But then when you think of
the journey to the cloud,
there's multiple steps.
The first is the migration.
And the ability to
de-risk it for clients
with prepackaged
migration services
from Deloitte, combined with
the next leg of the journey when
customers are looking
at transformation,
how do I change my business
processes leveraging
machine learning and analytics?
That generally involves a deep
requirement around industry
business process.
And so Deloitte's
industry DNA is also
something that's an important
part of this solution.
And then lastly, a
number of customers
just want a managed service.
They want to move
their solutions
or ERP solutions, S/4HANA,
example, into the cloud.
And they want to
essentially outsource it.
And so this new offering
that we worked together
with the Deloitte
teams so that there's
a turnkey managed
service that includes
both then management
of the landscape,
as well as bundling in
the Google Cloud Services
all in one turnkey
construct for the customer
is something we're seeing
customers quite interested in.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
I know Jan, you
talked a little bit
about the offerings
that will be created.
And I know you certainly, Pavan,
have worked sort of tirelessly
on this SAP offering construct
around digital transformation.
Can you share a little bit,
what does digital transformation
mean with SAP on GCP?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA:
Yeah, so essentially--
and I think Kevin also
touched upon the same topic--
our clients are into various
stages of the journey.
And they are looking our
help and Google's help
to help them make
the business case--
because a lot of them
are still struggling
to make a business case--
to move into the cloud,
get the full benefit of cloud.
So essentially what
we did is, we already
have a robust SAP implementation
services available,
and operate services available.
We laid over our Google and
Deloitte Cloud capabilities
on top of it to
create a storefront
where we can help client from
end to end building a strategy,
building a business
case, understanding
the benefit of cloud from
the business standpoint,
not so much from
technology only.
So initial taking them
through the journey
need to build a business
case, build a strategy,
and then moving more into the
implementation and migration.
Some of our clients are doing
a lift and shift migration
as a first step before they
fully realize the value of SAP
by moving to S/4HANA.
And some of them
are starting what
we call it a clean
ERP, clean slate,
leaving the legacy behind.
So we have laid build
artifacts solutions around it.
In fact, we had made
some strategic acquistion
to help client doing lift and
shift to Google Cloud Platform.
We are also building
adapters and integration
with the Google Cloud
Platform with our tool sets,
which makes it very
compelling, easy, and seamless.
And last but not
the least, I think
focusing more on managed
services and operate business.
We are seeing a great
momentum right now where
clients are adapting
Google Cloud Platform
and they need an SI who can
bring an end-to-end service
to manage and operate
them seamlessly,
provide the transparency
and the tool
sets to manage the
Google Cloud Platform.
So definitely all
of those services
under one umbrella, that's what
we are bringing to our clients.
TOM GALIZIA: So I think a
number of the things, the points
you've made is talking to
the landscape that we see,
the market landscape, and the
needs that our clients are
articulating.
Where are we-- and
this to the group--
where are we in
the game, in terms
of how big is that pipeline?
How fast is it going to convert?
Give us a sense of the
velocity that we're
likely to see over the
next 12 to 24 months.
Obviously early innings,
but the tipping point
could be quite quick.
JAN WAALS: I was going to
save some of my thunder
until the last couple
of minutes, frankly.
So as you know, and
Deloitte in front of SAP,
as well, before S/4
was even called S/4,
I predicted that there was going
to be a tsunami of opportunity,
basically, around S/4, even
put an exact date to it.
And I was proven right.
But the interesting
thing is what
most of the people in
Deloitte don't remember,
I actually made a
second prediction then,
where the timing is a
bit harder to predict.
But it was going to
be called tsunami 2.0,
an even bigger wave.
And that's the whole
combination of move
to cloud infrastructure, but
also SaaS solutions, even
for SAP S/4 as well, single
tenant, multi tenant.
There's going to be an enormous
wave that, frankly, the biggest
issue that customers and
consulting firms will have
in SAP is, frankly, around
talent because there's
going to be such a massive
wave of opportunity hitting us
over the next 12, to
years, frankly, to come,
that it's going to be
very difficult to manage
the workload.
TOM GALIZIA: And just
order of magnitude
in terms of size of the
prize, number of clients,
can any of you share some
of your thoughts on TAM?
JAN WAALS: I think
you could easily
say that over even
seven to 10 years,
you're talking
hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of business.
I mean, it's humongous.
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: Yeah.
I think when you look at SAP's
install base of just ERP alone,
it's roughly 60,000
customers plus.
And they're adding
new ones every day.
And as those customers move
from their traditional ERP
environments to
S/4HANA, those are
the times there's tremendous
business benefit there.
And as they do that
migration, that
is the opportune time
to move to the cloud
because you oftentimes need
to do a hardware refresh.
You may not have
the skills in-house.
So getting a managed
service where
you can get the
services and the cloud
all in a turnkey
migration, we're
seeing those things could
just go hand-in-hand.
TOM GALIZIA: Fantastic.
I mean, it's incredible
when you think
about the size of the wave
that-- you did predict it.
And we're about to surf
it with our clients,
and collectively as a
collaboration with SAP.
Seems like there are
a lot of offerings
that are being built
around these hosted SAP
on GCP solutions.
And I was wondering, Pavan,
given the role that you play
in terms of market facing,
how has Deloitte with Google's
teams, how are we
helping customers
move to GCP so that they can
take advantage of not only
the services that
are there today,
but what Kevin and the team
are shaping for tomorrow?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, so there
are multiple stages of clients
and their transformation
journey and our offering
associated with it.
So there is a set of clients
who are doing a lift and shift,
essentially just taking
their existing workload
and moving it to
the cloud to take
the benefit of Cloud Platform.
And then there are
other set of clients
who are just migrating from
their traditional databases
to leverage the
in-memory HANA platform,
HANA databases from SAP.
We consider mostly this is
lift and shift or technology
upgrade.
So we have acquired
a new solution
in the market called
ATADATA, which
helps us take these solutions
and do a mass-scale migration.
In fact, we have built a
factory, mass migration
factory, internally that
does this very quickly using
all the automation
and script around it.
The second part of
conversation that we
are having with our client is,
which is I think predominantly
happening right now, is S/4HANA
a greenfield implementation
because a lot of our
clients are thinking
that's the best way to start,
leaving all the legacy behind.
So we have built our
architecture, artifacts,
solutions A, to help them set
up, install, run SAP on GCP,
but also take the conversation
away from just the IS space
to platform as a
service, and how
we can leverage other feature
function of Google platforms,
such as APIs, as well as
Machine Learning and BigQuery
and Analytics, which
is a game changer here.
So those are the major
areas and major set
of options that we are
bringing to the client.
How we are helping our client,
obviously its a combination
of having a right SAP skill,
as well as having a right GCP
and Platform
skills, Cloud Native
app development skills,
and infrastructure skill
and architecture skill.
We are training and certifying
hundreds and thousands
of people in our US as well
as in our India practice
to get ready to
help this tsunami
that Jan is talking about.
So definitely that's where
we are working, mostly.
TOM GALIZIA: Perfect.
You touched on lift
and shift and migration
and the importance of
enabling tools to get there.
And you mentioned ATADATA.
I'm not sure the audience really
knows what that stands for,
what it means.
And I also think it's very
complementary to Velostrata,
acquisition by Google.
So it's worth,
probably, a couple
of sound bites on that from
some of you on the panel.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Yes,
I can talk a little bit
about ATADATA.
Essentially, it is
Anywhere To Anywhere.
So you move from any combination
of your source platform
to on any combination on
any of the Cloud platform
you can go with.
It is basically take the
application as a container
and move exactly as it is.
And if you want to
transform what you're doing,
there are a certain level of
transformations also possible.
For example, you are changing
your operating systems,
those things can be handled
as part of the ATADATA tool.
And Kevin, if you want
to talk a little bit
about the Velostrata--
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: Sure.
And Velostrata complements that
by enabling you to essentially
shadow your environment on
prem and into the cloud,
or if you're running
on another cloud
and you need to
change the hypervisor
to run natively on GCP.
So really, the two
work together to really
make the migration more
seamless for customers.
TOM GALIZIA: Perfect.
I want to dig a
little bit deeper
in some of the
previous points, again,
bringing the SAP
context to life.
So how is Google really
helping SAP and their clients?
You talked about the massive
install base really embrace
not only the technologies that
we see today that are available
today that they still
need to move to that,
but also that are
going to define
the next wave of technology
advancements that--
you talked about the portfolio
play of Alphabet Google
and bringing that to
bear-- but the other wave
of technology advancements
that are right in front of us.
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: Yeah, what
we see is that it's happening.
This wave is happening in kind
of a multi-horizon journey.
So customers are saying, I
want to move my existing ERP
landscape, as an example,
or other SAP products
into the cloud as phase one.
I want to get the TCO reduction.
And I want to get the agility.
But then, in phase
two, once I actually
have all the data in
one place, how do I now
leverage that data
for better insights
and actually transform
my business process
and create new business models?
And so in phase one,
what we're seeing
is that as customers move,
one of the biggest things,
the benefits that they see
in moving to Google Cloud
is not only our
price performance--
and there's ample analyst data
that we have the best price
performance-- but it's
about reliability, security,
and network.
So from a reliability
perspective,
again, lots of analyst data that
we have the best uptime, which
is so critical
when you're running
mission-critical
solutions like SAP
because when SAP shuts down,
the business shuts down.
And from a security
perspective, it's
some of the most sensitive
data, whether that's
financial data, customer
data, et cetera.
And so this ability
for our cloud to be--
the security that
we deliver, there's
a lot of uniqueness
to that in that we
build every part of
the hardware stack.
And we have a root of
trust chip built in so
that we can ensure the security.
In fact, many of you are
familiar with recent security
vulnerabilities at the
chipset with, like,
[? Spectre ?] and Meltdown.
Google actually identified those
vulnerabilities, patched it,
and announced it to the world.
So security is one of
the key differentiators.
And then from a
network perspective,
not only in the
network performance,
but we have the largest
network in the world.
And we have, actually,
enough network,
enough fiber under the
ocean and so forth,
to support a 400%
growth in the network.
If the internet grew 400%,
we have enough network.
And we're not stopping there.
And so this is tremendous scale.
This is the same scale of
all the Google products
you know and love today,
brought to enterprise
mission-critical systems.
We spent over $30
billion on investment
in order to deliver the
market-leading platform.
And then as customers
move to the second wave
of their journey, leveraging
market-leading capabilities
like TensorFlow machine
learning and BigQuery analytics,
that enables customers to not
only just harvest insights,
but actually start to come up
with completely new business
models.
TOM GALIZIA: I was in the
leadership circle yesterday.
And it was great to see PH
kind of articulate the journey
that our customers have to
go on, very much in line
with what you described.
So for those of you who
maybe have missed that,
we can connect you to that
methodology and approach.
It's simple, yet hard to do.
I do want to come
to-- and by the way,
I'm still lobbying to
see Google's Navy, which
includes ships and submarines,
in case you didn't know.
It's public, but we're trying
to get that invite, maybe,
to a lucky winner
in the audience,
we can make that happen.
What is-- and by the way,
my son really wants that.
He wants to do that.
Age 11, he thinks
Google is very cool.
Deloitte Open Cloud,
also very, very cool,
and another enabling
technology that we have.
Can you share a little bit about
what is Deloitte Open Cloud?
How does it work?
Why is it easy to consume
for enterprise clients?
Either Pavan or--
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, so
essentially Deloitte Open Cloud
is a framework that
we have developed
with a future in the mind.
As we are moving into cloud
space, a lot of our clients
would, whether we
like it or not,
would be into a
multi-cloud environment.
And we would see
some application
running at one cloud.
Another would be
running another cloud.
So our Open Cloud really
provides a framework
to manage and give a
single pane of glass
for all the applications
running at different clouds.
So there is a
cloud-to-cloud integration.
There are all the
essential services aspect
of managing a platform of
any of the public cloud
provider, anything that
is essential from devops,
automation, infrastructure
management, logging,
monitoring, security,
reporting, and billing solutions
around it, as well
as, as we move
to the second layer
of PaaS layer,
we will have to manage the
custom-built app, as well.
So Deloitte Open Cloud is our
branded offering in the market
to manage any of the application
from top to bottom, end to end,
as a managed services platform.
TOM GALIZIA: And maybe speak
to the contractual element.
Why is it an easy contracting
mechanism for clients?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA:
So what we are doing
is, instead of client going
to an SI or a provider
for services, going to a cloud
provider for subscription,
our Open Cloud
allows you to have
a single place or single
shop go through Deloitte.
We have done all the
contracting behind the scene
with major cloud providers,
such as Google Cloud.
And essentially,
we are the front
to the client, a single
SLA-based offering
to the client.
So essentially, we
take the ownership
of providing the SLA based on
Google Cloud Platform managing
end to end.
Not only that, even if tomorrow
you want to extend and enhance,
you are just dealing with us
from all the major application
tier to the
infrastructure management,
as well as the
infrastructure itself.
So this essentially simplifies
the transformation journey
that we are talking about.
And not only that, Kevin
touched upon having
more of a bare-metal option.
So we are also extending
this through other networking
solutions to extend our Open
Cloud to a bare-metal option,
as well.
TOM GALIZIA: Making it easy
to consume is critical.
And being able to meet the
client wherever their needs are
is critical, so Open
Cloud does that.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Absolutely.
TOM GALIZIA: Jan
and, I think, Kevin,
as well, we're here in
sunny, beautiful California.
But the global frame
is really important.
You're our global
leader for SAP.
What are some of the nuances
around the world that you're
seeing around the demand for
this service, SAP on GCP,
and also predictions
to that extent.
Are you seeing innovation
out there that we can
bring here or here to there?
Just curious what you both see.
JAN WAALS: So twofold, I guess.
One is in the old days--
I mean, old as in up until two
or three years ago, maybe--
something new would come
along and we would do
a massive project or something.
And then eventually, 18 months
down the road or something,
you would deliver this.
If you see now, actually, it's
sort of like the opposite.
Yeah, eventually you'll deliver
something big at the end,
maybe, too.
But along the way,
now, there's a lot
of things you already can do.
So already came up, like lift
and shift, you can do that now.
You don't have to wait until
the journey is complete to S/4.
You can just take
what you have now
and already go for a
lower TCO, as well.
But that's sort of like
the cloud migration
piece, which, in itself,
will be huge, of course.
But then if you look at
IoT-enabled supply chain,
there's an enormous
interest around that.
And of course, if you look
at AI and machine learning,
and there as well, it's
not just about waiting
to design this around S/4 only.
There are certain things
where there's a business case
to do that along the way,
even where there's sometimes
massive opportunity for
savings with specific business
processes to utilize
the standard SAP
scenarios, around
Leonardo, as an example.
But in combination with Google,
it makes it even more powerful.
And what you see is, I
think, over the next year
and years is a combination
of SAP making investments,
Google making investments,
firms like Deloitte making
investments.
We're going to see enormous
possibilities along the way.
TOM GALIZIA: And I know you
were just in Europe last week
trying to get a feel for
that landscape, versus APJ,
versus here in the US,
what either of you guys
are seeing in terms of
pipeline demand, conversion,
different consumption types?
JAN WAALS: Yeah,
it's interesting.
You know, one of the reasons
why way back when I'd predicted
the tsunami was for
multiple reasons.
One is the first sign of a
tsunami is water level recedes.
You see the investment
in older technology--
SAP, ECC as an example--
drying up, and then, of
course, a new wave forming.
But also, a tsunami, it
sort of ripples, of course.
And somehow in the
US-- because of,
maybe, the economic cycle,
as well-- but just business
is maybe a bit more willing
to invest in new things
immediately.
Europe a bit more
cautious, maybe.
Asia-Pac a little
bit in between.
But what you see now is
that ripple effect, where
I used to get phone calls
from people in Europe, like,
hey you're talking about a
tsunami, when is it hitting us?
And I was like,
well, it's coming.
They were like, well, it's not
here yet, it's not here yet.
And then all of a sudden,
you get the panicking phone
calls asking for resources
and help and assistance
because all of a sudden
the pipeline explodes.
And that's sort of the
phase we're in right now
where the pipeline
has been building up,
the big projects
are about to start.
Some of them already started.
That's the phase we're in.
If you look at
EMEA and Asia-Pac,
that's coming, as well.
TOM GALIZIA: Perfect.
And Kevin, I know you and I were
in Canada several months ago.
And then we had our teams
in Europe pushing pretty
hard on GCP and SAP on GCP.
Some of the things that
you're seeing from the Google
perspective?
KEVIN ICHHPURANI:
Yeah, I would say
that when you think of
SAP on GCP globally,
we're seeing adoption
happening throughout the globe.
But there are certain
countries that where
we're seeing the
adoption happen faster.
As Jan mentioned, the
US, clearly, UK, we're
starting to see a big
uptick in areas like France
and in Germany and in
the Benelux region,
as well as, I'd say,
Australia and Japan.
There's where we'll
probably see the largest
set of opportunities right now.
But like I said, this
is really spreading.
As Jan mentioned,
it is a tsunami.
We're seeing it spread to a
number of other countries.
And one of the things that's
going to be so important
is just for customers to
really prioritize and be ahead
of the curve because I think one
of the biggest challenges I see
is the services
partner community
needs to ensure that
the scale and the people
are on the ground in
order to help with these.
So planning ahead is really
important in this journey.
TOM GALIZIA: And I
mean, that brings
a great point around
potential friction
or bottlenecks
that we might have,
or capacity constraints
whether they're human
or technology-related.
Maybe some comments on the
early innings, where you're
seeing the friction points?
What's slowing this tsunami
from hitting faster versus it
taking its due course?
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: So
one of the things,
more and more countries
around the world
are expecting their
data to stay in country.
The data sovereignty
issues have become
pretty significant around the
globe, not just in Europe,
but in Asia and Latin
America and so forth.
And so we're putting up
new availability zones.
As I mentioned, we've put $30
billion in infrastructure.
We're putting up new
availability zones.
New data centers pop up
literally every month.
We have now 50 availability
zones around the globe.
And so from our side,
that's extremely important
to be able to serve customers
locally and ensure the data
sovereignty requirements.
TOM GALIZIA: Perfect.
You know, Pavan, I am curious.
There are a lot of options for
clients as to service providers
that they could
potentially choose.
So what is the Deloitte
difference here?
You know, I've spent
time in Sapphire,
latter stages of my
career, last couple two,
three years because of Google.
And that's one
impressive showing
that we have there in terms
of the Pinnacle Awards.
But what makes us different?
Why us to take you on
the cloud journey to GCP?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, so
there are various reason
that we are at the top and
one of the leading system
integrator.
But I'll touch upon a
couple of points here.
First is, if you look
at analysts report
and if you look at our
awards and recognition,
we have been getting
the Pinnacle Award
for last multiple years.
In fact, this year we also
got the Leonardo Partner
of the Year Award, which is
exceptionally well for us.
That proves our ability into
the space of machine learning
and Cloud Platform.
Also, Google's recognition for
us as a Partner of the Year
and our partnership around
going after digital transmission
with DAP.
So a lot to talk--
we're not talking, but
our analysts are talking.
Everybody is talking
that we do have a pole
position in the market
to help our clients go
through the journey.
In fact, we have the most
number of successful S/4HANA
implementation on
any cloud platform.
We have the most
number of solution
that is built around
Google Cloud platform.
So definitely, that's one area.
Second area is our talent pool.
I mean, more than 18,000
SAP practitioners,
and thousands of them has
been certified on SAP as well
as on Google Cloud Platform.
In fact, we have more
than 200 practitioners
who are certified together
with SAP and Google Cloud
Platform, which is a
unique skill that we need
to bring for all
of SAP clients when
we are talking about business
case to implementation
to migration to
operate business.
And we are certifying
more into our talent pool.
We are making lot
of acquisition which
is more related to this SAP
and cloud-specific area.
And the last point, I think,
which is the most important,
is the innovation.
I think we have the most
number of industry use case
and business use case that will
deliver value to our client,
how best you can leverage the
capability of a cloud platform,
such as Google Cloud
Platform or versus SAP Cloud
Platform running on the
Google Cloud Platform.
We have created more
number of assets
that really solve
the business problem,
or extend the features
functionality for digital core
beyond just the digital core
using those cloud platform.
So those innovations are
really making us a leader
in the market to help client.
And those are the real reason
that anybody would choose us
over other SI to help them.
If we have time,
I will definitely
talk about an innovative
solution that we have built
and maybe show you a
short demo around it.
What we call it is, it's an
automated invoice management
solution, which is build on
using Google Cloud Platform
capability as well as
SAP Leonardo capability,
starting all the way
from getting the invoice
and processing it and all the
way going up to the payment.
And that is a
solution that we are
productizing and
commercializing and taking
to the market along with
Google and SAP together.
And essentially what it does is
it uses Google Cloud Platform
storage unit.
It uses Google Vision
API, as well as
a TensorFlow model using Google
auto ML, machine learning,
at the front of it.
And at the backend, for GIIR
clearing and the payment part
of it, it is using SAP
Leonardo components,
so essentially really bringing
the power of our business
knowledge, along with the
Google Cloud Platform capability
and SAP capability together.
So if you are interested,
I can definitely--
TOM GALIZIA: Are you interested?
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: --play a demo.
It's very short demo.
TOM GALIZIA: Are you interested?
[AUDIENCE AGREES]
I think there's a
general interest.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: All right.
That's good.
TOM GALIZIA: Let's
get this thing going.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: Let's
get going with the demo.
TOM GALIZIA: I'm going to
come back to you, Kevin.
I promise.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA: So
essentially, as you can see,
it's going to run fast.
You have an option
of scanning invoice,
viewing an invoice when
invoice is created in SAP.
Here we are looking
at currently,
as you can see, the bucket.
There is no invoice left.
So we are picking a paper copy
or email or scanned copy right
now.
So you can see,
this as an invoice.
And apparently, we'll use Google
Vision API to scan this invoice
and the OCR characters will be
read through using Google API.
And behind the
scenes, the Auto ML
is running, which
is really getting
smarter as you keep scanning
more and more invoices.
So as you can see, we are
just uploading the invoice
at this point of time.
And it says
successfully uploaded.
Now if you go to
look at the bucket,
you should be able to see a
new invoice appearing there.
There you go.
So the actual physical copy
has been scanned, stored
into the Google Cloud Platform.
And now we are going
to look at the invoice.
So this is where
the AP clerk can
look at the actual, physical
invoice and the data that
has been read through
the scanner Vision API
and see if there is
any correction needed.
You can also see that
green bar on the top which
says the confidence
factor is 92%, which
means the ML is working
behind the scene
and intelligently trying to
read the characters of invoice.
At this point of time,
you can make a correction
if it is needed, but hoping
that as machine learning gets
smarter, you don't have to
make a lot of corrections here.
So this is the physical
copy coming from there.
And this is, on
the left side, you
will see what machine
learning and Vision API
was able to read through.
So if you go to the bottom,
you can have a Submit button.
And as soon as you
press the Submit button,
it's going to go to SAP
and create the invoice.
So let's see what it does there.
So it's just showing you
the different values--
unit price, quantity amount--
and press the Submit button.
It says you want
to submit it, yes.
And it's going to
create invoice, so 7381.
Let's remember the invoice
number here, long number.
And now we're going to go back
to the tiles in the front,
which is a Fiori app.
And now we are logging into SAP
and searching if the invoice
has been created.
So we're going to type the
same numbers, press Go.
There you go.
You can see the invoice
is already posted.
And if you click on it, it is
going to show you the invoice.
And remember, it
has some metadata,
which is a hyperlink going
back to Google Cloud Storage
and reading all the
data from there.
You see in the bottom, the
attachment link is there,
so you can definitely
open a physical copy
from the same screen there.
So you can imagine
all your data is--
you just press one click
called Submit, and that's it.
The invoice is
already created there.
And I think there's one step--
if you are really about the old
way of doing things, logging
directly into the SAP GUI, you
can run your bill transaction,
go for the company
code, and it is
going to show you if
that invoice is already
created there.
Just to make sure that
this Fiori app in the front
or in the backend,
you can log in
and you can see both
invoices are created.
This used to be a big issue.
You have to develop the
whole OCR capability,
go through a document
management solution.
But leveraging
Google capability,
you can do that very easily.
And the subscription costs
for Vision API and Google ML
is very low cost model as
compared to any other solution.
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: I think
one thing that's unique, too,
is versus the OCR
approaches of the past
is this learns over time.
So as these new invoices'
formats come to you every day,
it's learning.
And it's adapting on the fly.
PAVAN SRIVASTAVA:
Yeah, absolutely.
And that's a beauty of it, that
your effort keeps going down
as you keep going further down.
All right.
That's a demo.
TOM GALIZIA: I love it.
Well, we'll go to the audience
here in a minute for questions.
I do want to come back, Kevin,
to the ability to co-engineer
with you, with Google.
One of the things that was
appealing to the Deloitte team,
I think, was this idea of
co-engineer, co-create,
and innovate.
And so can you maybe
share some of the ways
that people like Deloitte,
as well as customers,
can co-innovate,
co-create with you?
We saw a solution
here that I know
our team worked with your
team to get it to done.
But--
KEVIN ICHHPURANI: Absolutely.
I think one classic
area of that is
in the areas of machine
learning and how we can
optimize business processes.
And there's some examples right
now where we're co-creating,
let's say, with SAP
and joint customers,
for example in retail.
We have customers--
we're working together
with a furniture company
that wants to bring
and essentially do image search
against all their catalogs.
So I can take a
picture of a desk
and it matches against
what pictures in the data
file within the SAP catalog.
There is a lot of work
that goes into that.
It takes an army
of data scientists.
It takes a lot of time.
With Auto ML, together with
our engineers and Auto ML,
we simplified that.
So it can literally
be done in hours, what
would take weeks or months.
And it's at a
fraction of the cost.
And so these are
the kind of things
we're doing together
with joint customers.
We're working with
customers that
want to take Google
Shopping's trends information
and enrich that into their SAP
assortment planning process
so that you have a richer
that takes into account
all of the trends that
are happening in the market.
We have customers that
we're working with
to take our adtech content,
our rich profile and propensity
to buy information,
and pull that together
with SAP's Omnichannel solutions
so that we can do things
like do precision marketing.
When you're doing
marketing, it's
only as good as the target
market that you've identified.
And so these are
the kind of things
we're doing in
order to really help
customers get to completely new,
innovative business processes.
TOM GALIZIA: I think at least my
experience has been the ability
to bring the different
pieces of Google Cloud, which
is phenomenal, and then Google
itself, which is bigger,
and then Alphabet more broadly
is really second to none.
So it's been great to see
how you orchestrate that
on your side with
important partners like us,
but also critical customers.
So--
[THEME MUSIC]